roll on his back yeah it is what zone
are we in are we in zone two
I don't know
we'll figure it out
[Music]
hey everybody
how's it going
how are you Adam I'm doing great man
it's great to be back here welcome back
back to roll on back in the studio dicks
it looks great I don't look great I
don't quite know what to do it's been I
checked it's been since November 10th
2022 Wow since we've done this WOW
feeling a little bit Rusty right you and
me both I've been just locked in a room
with no windows or doors I don't know
how I got in there they built it around
me uh-huh and then they there's a
there's a trapdoor and they fed me they
did yeah
the darkness Retreat is that what you're
talking about ding ding ding yeah so I
actually have a funny story about that I
I thought about doing that as a matter
of fact because I just the reason we
haven't done roll-on since since
November 10th right is I mean I had a
bunch of travel stuff and then I did
what I do every January which is I take
the month off and in this case I ended
up going to Australia and I can share a
little bit about that um in in a minute
but I was kind of looking at experiences
to you know kind of catalyze a little
bit of growth yes and uh and and the
Darkness retreat thing like came across
my transom and I looked into it there's
a there's a place I had I actually had
it in the outline where is it is it in
the Pacific Northwest well there's
there's multiple different places but
there's a place called Sky cave Retreats
which is in Ashland okay and it's kind
of like a little Boutique sort of
retreat center like Hotel situation but
yeah they you get a room and you
basically I think it is three days sixty
I think you can do six days something
like that I'm not sure uh and you're in
there you're in darkness for the entire
time and they they feed you food I think
through like a trapdoor thing but in a
way where no light ever like penetrates
the room so like during the day too
There's No Light No Light No Light No No
devices no nothing like utter total
complete darkness with no stimulus
listen Rich which actually sounds like
you're like wow that would be intense
and then the more you think about it you
realize how just utterly terrifying
right that does not sound like a
vacation to me what kind of resort is
this but I think as we speak yeah our
friend Colin O'Brady is in sconston
just such an experience of course he is
yeah he was talking about it I think
he's in the middle of it right
yeah so I thought about doing that good
for him and then I thought
I already live in a prison of my mind
like I should probably resolve some of
those things before I put myself in that
situation to torture myself like I guess
the idea is you you come to the silence
at the end right right yeah or you work
through that level of discomfort to
arrive at some level of like peace and
and and immersion in in presence but
isn't that like gotta go sideways though
for some people you right right I mean
isn't that what they did in Shawshank
Redemption with Andy Dufresne they put
him in the
it's voluntary it's voluntary solitary
confinement right except in the dark
it's a punishment it's not a retreat
well you know isn't an ultra endurance
event like hey Run 100 miles uh you
could get through that as a punishment
this is the mental version Spartan
challenge or a cold plunge or any of
these things that we sign up for
are you know they're all voluntary you
know exposure to different forms of
discomfort it's true no I get it I
understand the idea is to is to kind of
shortcut you to like some Shakti pod
moment of self-acceptance I'm just
saying
um I think I would rather Run 100 miles
to be honest with you it is a pretty
scary aspect right yeah anyway uh we got
through line one of the outline before
we got sidetracked which is why I love
doing this yes uh for those of you who
are who are uh tuning in maybe you're
you're new to this whole format or
perhaps uh the amount of time that's
left since the last time that we've done
this have has led to some kind of uh
memory failure uh situation so if that's
you this is the version of the show
where in the most General sense uh Adam
Mr Adam skolnick sitting across from me
and I
um play a little fast and loose with uh
items of interest that have caught our
fancy and our Whimsy and we share our
Curiosity on certain things it's a
little bit different from the normal
show that we do and it is also a format
that we have now kind of put under the
microscope and and maybe playing with in
the new year which we can talk about but
I think today is going to be pretty
standard except we're going to kind of
cut to the Chase and be be a little bit
lean it's going to be much more of a AMA
kind of listener question
focused type episode we're gonna get
some stuff off for Troll's mind let's
just clear let's clear the Slate it's
been three months let's unpack the bags
how about you I know
my goal when I come here is to share
nothing I want to share nothing personal
come on no no no come on no
um
how are you I'm going to check in
so I feel like I can I can describe the
essence of fatherhood I think it's
distilled
into these little moments and one of
them is my newfound appreciation for Ice
Ice Baby
uh-huh how long have you worked on this
joke
I'm just saying this is a true story go
ahead it's a true story
do you know what it's like like when you
like a song you never liked but as
caught is becoming ear worm for your
two-year-old and then it's been you know
a minute we're in different phases of
fatherhood but slightly go ahead so
somehow a while back he heard Ice Ice
Baby and couldn't stop saying Ice Ice
Baby so it became a go-to on the Zuma
playlist and over time at first I was
kind of hesitant to you know I never
liked the song much even even though I
grew up in in ice ice baby's era I never
really liked it that much even though I
admittedly it's catch a shocker I never
thought it was a good rap song
but now
now I I know it's a good rap song and is
this my love for Zuma
is it latent appreciation for the artist
that is Vanilla Ice is it just a good
rap song
I don't know it's confusing it's all
very confusing right so what is the
truism that you're extracting from this
experience my point is you can love
someone so much that you learn to love
the songs they love even if you don't
want to um there's a poem in there
somewhere yeah that's my hike that's a
joke more more a poem it's kind of
important I love the things that the
person you love loves right right
because he loves it he jumps around to
it and to be honest when it comes to the
point of the song where he's like A1A
beachfront Avenue
I say it out loud just like that that's
what I do well enthusiasm is is
infectious yeah thank you so I love I
love Ice Ice Baby now at me if you if
you must I love it all right yeah good
all right so we checked that box
fatherhood fatherhood distilled
um my foot is a little better better
it's better than it's been a long time
it's not perfect it might never be
perfect but it's uh I had that two PRP
injections my post tibial tendon has
reconstituted itself of its own accord
that worked well for you it's worked
well I'm running I've run I've done like
six runs in three weeks so it's not like
I'm I'm hammering it but I'm back doing
that I'm in the gym part of my rehab uh
Dr Goggins ordered me into the gym to
lift weights which is not my favorite
thing to do but I've been doing it
enjoying it with the great nicknur shout
out
um we were in Kauai we did a Sabbat we
did a mini sabbatical but not like a
total sabbatical about the whole family
yeah and uh that was awesome saw some
old friends in Kauai because I know we
both have a kawaii backstory and so that
was January for us we kind of skipped
out on a lot of the rain uh and other
than that it's just been kind of look
watching the Goggins book kind of happen
and unfold and that's been really
rewarding right so the last time we sat
down together was before the book came
out that's right that's right out in
January December it came out December
December right okay so uh I mean it did
I mean it did what you expected it to do
right like it did number one on Amazon
which is a crazy expectation to actually
set and then achieve but anyway did that
once again competing against uh not only
Michelle Obama but like the Royals yes
right so the Royal the Royal the Royal
smash up
but like mixing it up you know up there
I mean by all appearances it it it seems
like it's done fantastically well it's
done really well you know we we we did
we were number one for that week on
Amazon and then Harry came out but we've
been uh we were number one on Audible
for like five weeks I mean we were doing
really well can't hurt me got a bump out
of it yeah but is the audiobook
outselling yeah that's that's been the
way it's been even for can't hurt me I
think it's like I don't exactly know the
numbers but it's like 55 or 60 of its
audio right which of course the margin
you know doesn't even compare right
there's no cost no right right right
yeah right when you're self-publishing
that's massive yeah yeah when you're
self-publishing it's massive and uh and
and so that's been really cool
um and David hasn't even really been I
mean it was on The Joe Rogan podcast I
did a couple podcasts in that company
that's it yeah that's it so you know
it's it's it's pretty amazing that it's
staying up there and you know it's
I will say that like when we were
writing it David's idea was to he he was
always thinking about the reader from
the beginning and that experience more
than any other experience I've ever had
in writing including the Lonely Planet
books which are obviously service
journalism and you should be thinking
about the traveler I I don't think I've
ever been in a space of thinking about
my readers more than I am now and part
of that is David part of that obviously
being on the show with you as well
because you want you it is service in
its own way and uh and so obviously like
it wouldn't be
doing this well without the readers we
really appreciate you guys uh I can't
thank you enough for all the support
both personally for the Goggins books
you know we do care about giving this
content in a way that will motivate and
inspire you it does mean a lot that it's
working and uh also want to thank you
because you know I wouldn't even be know
who David was if it wasn't for your
original interview with him and well you
would have eventually yeah yeah it would
have eventually yeah yeah but then the
fact that we're like started there and
then to come full circle it's just it's
such a cool thing and so like to see
David who is this incredible you know he
really does set an example on so many
levels uh and I look up to him a lot
even more so than ever really personally
and uh and so it's just great to be a
part of it and and really thank all the
listeners out there who's been who's
been supporting it yeah it's cool man
yeah I'm proud of you I'm happy for you
I'm happy for David it's it's it's quite
you know a trajectory and
you know the books are powerful and they
do motivate and inspire people and you
know I'm sure countless lives are are
you know kind of permanently transformed
by his by his work and and you know the
work that you put in to making it the
best that it could be is like no small
thing yeah but you know it made me a
better writer like it made me better in
so many ways so it's like it's great to
have gone through that process and the
process is always different but the good
thing about writing is is a process you
can rely on the process
um when you've done it enough and really
the process is just continuing to to
distill it down and down and down does
it put you in a position where now
you're getting pitched to be a ghost
writer on other people's books well
that's happened you know do you want to
do that is that something you're
interested in doing that's happened
since can't hurt me was a hit like I've
I've periodically would get real offers
from like real Publishers and then just
random people who say hey I've got this
you know and some some of these random
people are Olympians or like you know
what I mean but but who are asking me
personally I have so far said no to all
of it I'm not against it obviously this
is the Golden Age of ghost riding we
talked about it I've talked of you know
we've talked about it it's obvious it's
the New York Times it's a story on J.R
moringer who's like the alphagostrider
who just did Harry's but Prince Harry's
book
um and so the fact that's out there
being talked about is interesting it is
this golden age of ghost riding so the
funny thing is you can get paid more as
a Ghost Rider than as a like writing
your own stuff which is kind of like
backwards right but typically when
someone asks me to write their book I do
my best to convince them to write their
book yeah that's what I do that's my
first move I think you should write your
book that's what I say well we'll talk a
little bit about that yeah in a minute
but but just to kind of wrap up
um
uh goings on with you you also just
published this New York Times story
which uh got a pretty good reaction
right you want to talk about that a
little bit yeah yeah I did a story on
lacba Sherpa who is
um she's a sherpa woman from Mount
makalu in in Nepal and she last climbing
season last may she became the first
woman ever to get 10 Summits of Mount
Everest she's the first woman ever to go
to hit the summit and make it back to
base camp alive there was another Nepali
woman who in the 90s reached the summit
but died on her way down and uh she was
the first to do it now she's the first
to get 10 Summits that's like a hallowed
number so if you're a sports fan it's
like 500 home runs or 3 000 hits in
baseball it's like this number only 36 I
think is the number of people have ever
done 24 of them are Sherpa and they're
all been men and so she's the first
woman to do it and her life story is
just tragic but also uh triumphant in
its way she survived domestic violence
she moved she's she's been working at
Whole Foods in West Hartford she cleaned
houses for a living she's an immigrant
woman she came over here after summing
it twice with a with a Romanian climber
and started Living in Hartford
Connecticut and has gone through the
ringer like as a single mom and but
still managed to get back there and add
to her Summit toll she was on the
mountain when the big Avalanche came
through base camp she was on the
mountain when they had the big
earthquake
um uh so she's you know her mentors have
died there uh she is just this
incredible woman that has never been
sponsored and so it was a great story I
was tipped off to it by a guy named Ben
Pryor listener of yours who has done
some research for me and he said you
should do this and at the time it was
like six weeks after she'd done the
climb maybe it was like a month and I
thought it's too late to do a story like
that now but then
um I tried to get a hold of her couldn't
do it and then uh bhadra Sharma who is a
New York Times Reporter out of Kathmandu
he and I worked on the Nim story
together I'm messaged him and I said hey
do you know lakba or have you ever met
her and it turns out he had he was there
when she came back to Kathmandu and had
this Heroes welcome and had a great
interview with her so we started there
we got in touch I interviewed her after
that and we just kind of collaborated on
this piece and as people have loved it
yeah yeah it's cool man yeah thanks I
turned it in in September and then it
didn't get published until like last
week
welcome to mainstream media publishing I
guess I don't know I think what happened
was I was finishing I interviewed her in
July August but I think in August but I
couldn't get to it until late September
because I was finalizing uh never
finished and then
um by the time I got to it I turned it
in like a week before the World Cup and
like the Time Sports desk was all in
yeah yeah in uh in Qatar interesting
Cotter um cool yeah Cotter I think
um are you working on anything else for
the times
there's a there's a swim race in late
April in Arizona have you heard of this
thing the scar race it's where it's this
four contiguous Lakes reservoirs in
Arizona that people swim in a stage race
and so I'm gonna do that story yeah I
haven't heard of that yeah monotonas
turned me on to it and so he won it last
year but this year apparently a lot of
really
um established and and well regarded uh
Open Water swimmers who've got like the
resumes on these guys are insane right
um uh they're all going to be there so
it should be a more interesting kind of
weird Carnival to follow around in
Arizona cool uh so that's on my radar
but other than that just finished uh
just finishing up this other big project
and
um excited to talk about that at some
point when appropriate when appropriate
cool yeah man how are you good good to
have you back yeah thanks man how was
the baby back uh sabbatical was great
I'll get into it in a second before that
I just want to make sure I make this
announcement which is
that uh we are finally reprising our
plant power Italia Retreat this is
something we've done every year up until
kovid and then we canceled it a couple
years in a row and last year it was sort
of on the fence and ended up deciding
not to do it we are going to do it um
this year it might be the last time that
we do it uh it's going to go down April
22 to 29 right now we're about half sold
out so I think that leaves about I don't
know somewhere between 15 and 20 open
spots at the moment
um and it's a pretty remarkable
um
kind of uh life-changing experience to
spend a week with a group of people
cooking
doing nutrition hiking trail running
doing yoga meditating touring you know
Tuscany you know hanging out music like
live podcasting kind of sessions like we
do tons of great stuff we have special
guests it's it's really quite
um quite something uh and so I'm really
looking forward to it special guest
meeting like yoga teachers or like yeah
every year like we've had different kind
of people like and we'll figure that out
at some point I'm sure you know TBD but
it's always pretty cool we've had the
happy pear guys come for example and
we'll do like a live podcast with them
that kind of thing and we do it at this
place called aisolana which is this
incredible
um agriterismo is like a working farm
but it's beautifully appointed like
Villa and accommodations with like two
pools in this beautiful yoga room and
dining hall and it's nestled sort of
halfway between Siena and Florence like
just an incredible you know part of the
world uh very sky-caved and it's very
this is a very skycare the antithesis of
the sky cave right like uh you know
hanging out with like amazing people
doing really high Vibe [__] so that
sounds cool to you you can learn more
about it at our plant
powerworld.com our plantpowerworld.com
I'll put that link up in the show notes
again
um about half full so if you're
interested I'm pretty sure it's going to
sell out quickly so jump on that and
then just to you know kind of goings on
recently with me yes I did the
sabbatical but prior to that we haven't
done a roll-on because I was traveling
I went to Hawaii to crew for the
Ultraman World Championships which is
the race that I did a number of times
like you know 10 years back I hadn't
been back I've been back to the big
island but I hadn't been back to that
race and that race is is really so much
about you know not just the Aloha Spirit
of Hawaii but also like Ohana like
family right and and you know giving
back is is kind of a fundamental aspect
of participation in the race and and
that was kind of a glaring Omission in
my relationship or history with the race
like I always felt compelled or
um this you know this this desire and
need to go back and and serve the race
that had given me so much and an
opportunity arose to go and crew for a
friend of mine Howie Nordstrom who was
competing he asked me and I said of
course this is great like he's asking
right at the moment where I thought like
I need to do this anyway right
um and it was it was uh it was it was
cool liked it was weird and cool to be
back there after so long right so much
of it is exactly the same like it's sort
of um you know it is to the racist
credit it has not like like sort of uh
succumbed to the pressures of
commercialism like it's very much you
know still in its roots of of what it is
in in that kind of Purity as opposed to
these under-mile races that have like
mushroomed in terms of attendants
sponsors get involved in and then they
grow into some you know kind of big
money-making Enterprise and it loses
sort of its Soul like Ultraman is not
that like it's still like wow this is
exactly the same as it was same people
some of the people who were racing when
I was racing are still doing the Race do
you think it's because it's so hard that
like that the the demand is still not
great or do you think it speaks to just
I don't think so I mean there are like
you know when they're Moab there's the
Moab 240. like there's a lot of hard
stuff out there right I think there has
been a conscious you know concerted
effort to keep it that way on purpose
like there's no intentionality yeah
um to keep it small like only you know
30 to between 30 and 40 participants Etc
and it was great it was great to be back
and reconnect with that you know part of
myself and it brought back a lot of
memories and then to serve Howie and get
him you know across the finish line and
you know that race is hard for everybody
and it had its highs and its lows and
all of that
um and to be on that side of that
equation and appreciate just how
challenging the crew role is and and
being in that service capacity was you
know an amazing experience and I did it
alongside another friend of Howie's this
guy Ryan smoke who is an Iron Man
athlete who
um is one of those guys that uh does it
in partnership with a challenged athlete
like he pushes a younger kid yes but
really cool guy we had fun serving Howie
and it was you know it was hard and it
was there were highs and lows and all
that kind of stuff and it was cool to
meet some of the younger athletes and
and also see how uh the quality of
athletes uh continues to improve like on
the women's side especially like DD
griesbauer who's a very accomplished uh
former Iron Man professional triathlete
who's Now 52 just absolutely like
crushed it rewrote all the records got
third overall which dominated the whole
thing and and was amazing and that was
really cool to see
um on the men's side Richard Thompson
from Australia got first and this guy
Stephen Keller who's a veterinarian got
second and you know those guys were both
just you know Superstars and and uh
excelling you know at a pretty high
level so it was it was cool a full
circle moment to be back and I feel like
that chapter has kind of like okay you
know like it's complete now Julie was
like if you go back and do that do you
think you're going to want to do that
race again right or some other kind of
disability I was like no I did it like I
I had that experience I learned what I
wanted to learn and what I needed to
learn from it I went back and
contributed to it and it feels like
complete what about Ultra in general
I don't know I mean the back has to get
healed right yeah you know and that's
not
the case at the moment right so I can't
really make any of those predictions
until I figure out how to get to the
other side of that fair enough is longer
but that's pretty cool to be able to do
that and then and then I think you
remember you telling me that there was
this cool banquet afterwards and you got
to say your piece too right
um You had to speak to the no I didn't
speak I mean there was a bit like they
do a banquet at the end and every every
athlete gets to go every Podium and
share their experience of of you know
participating in the race and so you get
to hear all of these stories and all
their flavors and and everybody's got a
crazy story right like you don't sign up
for something like that unless you're
you're like you know kind of living
Outside the Box nobody has an easy day
yeah and you know all the different
flavors of that yeah are are pretty cool
and it was also cool like
to go back and know like oh like some of
these people like listen to the podcast
yeah cool too yeah that was that was
really funny I would imagine yeah I'm
sure there's people that were there that
because they read your book or heard the
podcast there has to be some there were
a couple yeah there were a couple people
who yeah that well that was the initial
spark or you know hearing about the race
just and and frankly like David Goggins
like reading about Goggins doing
Ultraman was a spark for me right right
so that lineage continues which is
pretty great yeah
um but I returned from Hawaii and then
you know almost immediately uh while I
was in Hawaii
um my College film coach skip Kenny
passed away so when I returned I had to
go up to Fresno for I didn't have to I I
drove up to Fresno for a memorial for
him
he was 79 years old
um and and that was a interesting
experience to reunite with a bunch of
teammates from my swimming days many
people I haven't seen in decades some
people I've stayed in touch with but
most for the most part like lots of
people I just I didn't know I thought
maybe a ragtag group of a couple Bay
Area people might show up but there were
a lot like a lot of swimmers over the
over the many years that he coached that
showed up and and that was pretty cool
and and you know kind of analogous to
the Ultraman experience like another
kind of like
full circle moment like putting an end
cap on you know a life experience uh you
know in sort of a sense of of completion
and and also you know sort of a
resolution to a relationship with a
complicated guy who you know was very
successful he you know arguably one of
the most successful nc2a collegiate
Athletics coaches of all time right
across any sport right because his
winning streak and his success speaks
for itself he's the John Wooden of
swimming basically right yeah and you
know had like I don't even know the
stats off the top of my head but like
you know so many nc2a championships like
an incredible streak of winning pac-10
championships the number of Olympians
nc2a Champion you know individual
athletes that have passed through the
program it's like it's it's pretty crazy
and you know I have conflicting emotions
about the whole experience because on
the one hand I'm so proud and to have
been you know a member of those teams
and purchase it's like a it's such an
honor to you know have competed and
trained with so many great athletes
during the Heyday that Heyday in which
Stanford was the reigning you know
number one swimming program in the world
but also you know like Reckoning with
the fact that you know at least spy
stuff like skip didn't work as a coach
right and it left me kind of reflecting
on on mentors that I've had in general
in my life and and the role that this
show kind of plays in terms of providing
the kind of people and then what is the
relationship to like on an unconscious
level I started this podcast right and I
started inviting these people on who I
guess on some level I'm I'm I'm I'm sort
of like well how can this person Mentor
me now at least for two hours and then
sharing that there is there seems to be
some kind of connective tissue between
those two interesting
and is that why you went and I don't
want to jump on you like push the the
outline we have here but you did just do
this intense therapy week too like like
uh was that that was before Byron Bay
right right so then so then I get back
from the perfect time for that right
yeah and I'm thinking like what am I
gonna do you know what am I gonna
you know I'm trying to figure out some
kind of growth Catalyst yeah to kind of
shake me out of my stasis a little bit
beyond just going to a nice place and
relaxing and that's where the idea of
the uh the sky cave retreat thing came
up which I quickly dismissed thinking
you know I have some I still got some
some like demons in the closet like if
I'm in a dark room for six days without
having ever really confronted that
um in an honest way what's that gonna
look like that might not go so well
right so maybe I should
find a therapeutic modality to kind of
deal with some stuff that's just been a
hum in the background for you know most
of my life
and that's where the idea of of doing a
week
of family of origin therapy came up uh
at Paul Conte's
clinic in Portland so listeners may or
may not remember that I had Paul on the
podcast he is a world you know one of
the leading experts on on trauma
and you know realizing that I have all
this stuff in my past you know I've done
a lot of work and I've come a long way
and I've you know grown Etc but you know
there's always more growth to be had and
there's a lot of stuff from like you
know early childhood that I just haven't
really unpacked and uh made peace with
and
um I've noticed that it comes up in
certain Behavior patterns like with my
wife or in the way that I parent my kids
and Julie is often the one to point out
like hey you're you know you're kind of
mimicking this pattern that you said you
didn't want to do or that is something
that you know was something your parents
did that you didn't like
um so she's always like you know I'm
like oh wow you're right like I am doing
that why do I do that when everything
about me is trying to not do that and be
kind of in opposition to that right yeah
and some sometimes it's just it's so
embedded in you right right so part of
just who you are it's hardwired into
your system because it was implanted
there at such a young age and I just
felt like here I have this time like I'm
gonna go really dig into this and it was
an incredible experience you know five
days of like you know eight hours a day
working with a team of different
therapists uh to really you know figure
out why I have certain latent anger
issues or resentments and
you know how to really kind of work
through them and and and transmute them
and make peace with myself and the
people that I love and you know
obviously you're not going to solve
everything in a week but right uh you
know coming out of that with a lot of
clarity and and uh and understanding and
and like tools has been like revelatory
it's been incredible yeah incredible so
is that is that is are you doing like
the
like
um you say holotropic breathing exercise
is that like a lot of hypers and I put
that like in the outline like you know
one of the one of the kind of triggers
for me that made me realize like I have
a lot of stuff like percolating in my
unconscious is an experience I had doing
holotropic breathing
um many years ago uh I've had good
experiences with holotropic breathing
experience but on this one occasion uh
and this has happened like two or three
times I did a very intense holotropic
breathing uh exercise with a group with
Julie and in the wake of that
felt this overwhelming sense of of like
anger like like almost like Rage which
is I'm not I don't I'm not an angry
person yeah you're not a yeller or
anything and I literally had to go into
a room and like shut the door and be
away from people for
more than a day like almost 48 hours to
like reset and it was very disorienting
disorienting and confusing like why why
did that happen like what is you know
what is going on there and it just made
me realize and this was many years ago
like hey I got there must be something
you know right driving this like I don't
know why that is and and uh and so that
was always in the back of my mind like
you know you need to if you really want
to you know be whole and and and free
yourself from whatever that is like
you're gonna have to go towards it
so six six days of of intensive therapy
it was or eight days five days five days
yeah Monday through Friday and then
great and then you get on a plane to
Byron and
that's a good rewards holidays and
holidays with the family and then uh and
then yeah it took took a couple weeks in
in Byron Bay to like kind of reset which
was it's like my favorite place I love
it yeah yeah and this is the fourth year
that I've done like a you know break of
this nature to really just
um
you know stop everything and and you
know go Inward and
um meditate and write and engage in a
little Solitude Sun surf you know all
that good stuff
um and it was fantastic you know uh I
did I did do one podcast while I was
there I did yeah so you know this guy
Ned Brockman yes the runner he's the
best yes yes yes I was like I'm in
Australia like you love Brockman he's
like you know an Australian hero right
now this dude like ran all the way
across Australia he's the most
Australian dude of all Australians with
the bleach blonde mullet and like you
know you can't even like his his like
Australian slang and vernacular is like
so you know like hence that you're like
what I don't even know what he's talking
about but you can't help but fall in
love with this guy like he's very
um he's so Earnest right and he's young
he's like he just turned 24. until it
reminds me about what he did
so he after only running for two years
he only had like two years of running
experience decides he's going to run all
the way across Australia which is in the
range of of running across the United
States it's about the same except like
you're in the middle of nowhere if
you're in the outback there's a lot of
bugs a lot of like you know these
apparently like these trucks like the 18
wheelers they go They're called cargo
trains or something like that because
they drive together so it'll be like a
whole bunch of them at once and there's
not a lot of
um shoulder and you know so there's a
lot of like harrowing experiences that
he had
um
um but it's like I gotta meet this guy
right and when he when he when he
finally finished and ended up in in
um Bandai there were like thousands of
people to greet him five thousand ten
thousand estimating numbers but it was
quite the thing right like all of
Australia turned up to like support this
guy so cool and so anyway I did do a
podcast with him did you did you rent a
studio space
so friend of the Pod and personal friend
Simon Hill who is a Byron Bay resident
yes he was like my sort of Sherpa
introducing me to people he hooked me up
with this place called soma in Byron
which is a 28 acre Meditation Retreat
Center
um that is owned and run by these two
guys uh Gary gurrow who's a meditation
uh Vedic meditation teacher and this guy
Peter ostick who's a who's who's sort of
an entrepreneur who is the kind of
financial partner in all of this
um and it is the most beautiful
Meditation Retreat Center I've ever seen
um and I'm not alone in thinking that
because Hulu and they built it
apparently like right before lockdown
and covet and all of that okay and they
complete it
lockdown happens so they can't even do
host Retreats but Hulu came along and
said hey we'd like to rent this place
for this limited series we're doing with
Nicole Kidman that was called like nine
perfect strangers do you remember that
show I do I vaguely remember it was like
a cult Guru or something like that I
haven't watched it but yeah apparently
the whole series takes place at this
Meditation Retreat Center which is like
beautiful modern architecture and
Rolling Green Hills and like Incredible
or whatever so anyway
um Peter and and Gary made the the space
available for us to record there oh cool
yeah so that'll be coming out at some
point
um but yeah I loved Byron just brought
my bike you know rode in the Hills there
it's it's it's like there's a lot of
influencers there there was like I think
there was some sort of show about that
like a funny reality show about the
Australian influence I think there's a
show called like like a reality show
called like Byron Bays or something like
that but I was told not to watch it that
it would ruin my my relationship with
this beautiful it might please it might
I've seen a little bit but there are a
lot of cool people there like but my
other my other Sherpa is this guy Ben
Gordon shout out to Ben yeah who who is
sort of a mayor of of Byron he grew up
there and he's a drummer in a in a
pretty successful heavy metal band
called Parkway Drive oh cool
um and he also owns this place called
the Byron General store which is kind of
like the cool place to go have brunch or
breakfast okay have your green smoothie
healthy food he's plant-based he's a
meditator
uh and you know he's in this like
successful rock band but he's into like
surfing and
he I got to hang out with him and he
took me surfing I cut my finger open it
was fun though and introduced me to a
bunch of people and you know was able to
go to his house for dinner I just was my
point being like I was made to feel very
at home yeah in a place that's very far
away from my home it felt very much like
a home for me yeah it's like a blend of
like uh Hawaii there's Hawaii there's
California there's like you know what I
mean there's like a mix of it sounds
like a hippie yeah right a lot of
natural organic markets and vegan food
places and stuff like that so to me it
was like Topanga meets Maui me with a
like a light dusting of Ireland like
when I was riding my bike and the hills
would be these incredible ranches and
everything is so green like these
rolling fields and you know but then you
have like 80 degree water and just Beach
breaks in every direction I mean
incredible like you know very surfable
breaks all over the place like
it's pretty cool super cool man anyway
so it was good did you cry in the
departure Lounge
um I did not no I did not I'm always on
the lookout my ears in the departure
Lounge of a place like that I did not no
um we got to take a break in a second
here but um before that I I will say
I'll kind of round out this this story
by just saying that it was very
productive in terms of cracking open a
new book project and getting more custom
on that which I'm pretty excited about
and you were with me the other day when
we were with our mutual friend and um
literary agent bird level so I was able
to show him uh shout out bird level shut
up bird
um the pages uh that you showed them
yeah I showed them some stuff oh because
you were talking about I had to leave
and you showed him he had to leave and I
was like let me show you what I'm doing
and he was very happy like Adam's gone
is safe let's show them the pages so
anyway I feel really and he was so
excited about that yes I'm excited
that's so cool man you know like because
I was listening to the Seth Godin
podcast you did recently and you were
talking about like this drive to get
back to writing but this kind of like
this block because you're you're diving
into the podcast and you have all these
commitments but you there's a part of
you there's like the thing about writing
that I found is 90 of it is dealing with
this this insect gnawing at your brain
until you deal with it right like it
doesn't go away right I mean it does not
go away you can try to like it's like
the cordyceps in Last of Us like eating
away your your life your brain stem it
is so now you're dealing with it and
then it kind of quiets down and quiet
not only does it quiet down you actually
feel good about you like you're like oh
now I feel like a normal person right
you feel a little bit more annoying when
you're like yeah attending to it when
you're when you're ignoring it yeah you
walk around like just angsty yeah all
the time right it's it's cool man I
can't wait to read some stuff and and
I'm really excited for you so let's take
a quick break and then we're gonna do
some listener questions a few more
things to say about uh the future of
roll on and and kind of 2023 in general
and uh yeah it's gonna be awesome so
stick around I feel like most people
people want to eat better they want to
improve their diets absolutely have you
heard of it I've heard of it this trips
up so many people we thought hey we know
a couple things about how to do this a
few so we created this thing called the
plant power meal planner that is this
beautiful offering whereby you gain
access to literally thousands of
plant-based recipes that you can totally
customize based upon your preferences
your allergies your peccadillos it
integrates with grocery delivery so all
the ingredients that you need get
shipped right to your door so you can
make the stuff that you've pre-selected
and we all could use a little
inspiration and support when preparing
meals for our families in our busy lives
so we hope you join us no matter what
your eating style is we have our arms
open wide and we've saved you a space at
our family table to join us in eating
more healthy vibrant plant-based meals
and if you're looking for the perfect
holiday gift for a loved one right now
for a limited time we're offering twenty
dollars off meal planner gift cards
through December 15th visit
meals.richeral.com to claim the offer
again for twenty dollars off meal
planner gift cards from now until
December 15th visit meals dot
richroll.com
all right everyone we're back we're
going to get into some listener
questions before that though we
mentioned earlier that we're going to be
exploring a few format changes with roll
on so let's talk about that for a hot
minute let's do it so I think what we're
going to do is uh is move Rolanda once a
month and then for the other midweek
episode we're gonna play around with
some new kind of supplemental ideas and
we're also going to iterate on roll on
we're gonna you know I don't know push
the envelope here yes I think there's
there's a sense that at least my sense
is that uh Adam is a very talented man
and the the format in which we are
engaging with roll on right now I'm not
sure takes advantage of your best
talents and I think there are better
ways to to use this opportunity to be uh
uh you know a better servant to the
audience I 100 agree not today though
because we're just bullshitting and
banishing and people are like what are
you even doing like why am I listening
to this right like this kind of I'm I am
a good bullshitter you're just not as
good as well have we provided value yet
for the audience I don't know you know
I'm excited about doing some original
reporting with you doing some uh like
we're gonna I think the idea is to
script it a bit more and to do kind of
uh segments and and and this is what
we've talked about we don't really fully
know what's gonna happen but the thought
was to put a little more pre and
post-production into it and create one
idea is to create a uh an audio magazine
that reflects kind of the ritual pod
universe and kind of dive into some cool
subject matter and if we're only doing
one a month we have the time and the you
know kind of bandwidth to do something a
little bit more elevated okay just a
little more creative and and uh like a
little put more resources in because so
many people are just turning on by bikes
now and like you've done that and you're
great at it but fun to see you know uh
to create in a different way and I think
people who love the banter because I we
got some calls about like there's some
people who just love this format the
banter will be there we're going to sit
down and talk about it we're not going
to just like throw some segments
together and not talk to each other the
banter's gonna be there it's just going
to be in a different kind of way yeah
yeah and you know on that note
I think it's important to throw it out
to the audience like what you know yeah
what would what would be most beneficial
for you audience member
uh in terms of how Adam and I use this
you know opportunity to to serve you and
maybe the best place to let us know
would be in the comments section on
YouTube
um because that's an easy kind of
One-Stop place to go and canvas through
that stuff perfect so if you're like
we're talking about if you think about
it from an audio magazine perspective
like what are the Departments you'd like
to see like what are the worlds you'd
like us to explore and kind of and
sometimes it might just be
like one thing we've thought about is a
q a with uh someone from the ritual
audioverse some of it could be an
original report like NPR or this
American lifestyle reports and and
anything in between so and some of it's
going to be just Rich kind of speaking
his mind and writing some stuff and
sharing where he's at and uh just like
we're doing now but just a little more
elevated yeah and a little bit more
creative I would say yeah right
um and I think you know my perspective
is always I want to serve the audience
like if it's working for you is it not
working I don't want to waste anybody's
time and I think now you know everybody
there's a lot of content out there
there's a lot of choices right and so I
want to be in a position to be
delivering at the highest level the
needs and the desires and the wants of
the person who's taking time out of
their busy day to check this out right
and if we're missing the mark like I'd
like to know that yeah how can we do
better what would be interesting and
then also us on our own like pushing the
career of envelope and trying to think
of things that that aren't being done
right now that we think that we could
you know do well and executing on that I
think is exciting very exciting I'm
excited to be a part of it so should we
dive into some questions now let's do it
we're doing it a little bit differently
this time there was a lot of questions
because we had been we hadn't been doing
this for a couple of months so we had a
lot of stuff in the voicemail so what I
did is kind of combed through and found
some subject matter that I'm going to
paraphrase like headings like top like
sort of themes yeah yeah so these are
questions that have come in in various
forms uh more than once and that's where
we're that's where we're going to start
so let's start uh we're gonna Dive Right
In
the first question we're going to handle
is uh tips on Breaking Bad Habits and
when do you know that a bad habit is
actually an addiction such as gaming or
Doom scrolling this one's spurred by a
listener whose Iron Man training got
waylaid by travel and a gaming addiction
so the listener was training for an Iron
Man and something happened
and he got off his game and then got on
to gaming yeah like video games I think
gaming was always a thing yeah Warcraft
I think it was right yeah and that and
that like just cratered his creator
created everything yeah everything went
into Warcraft I love it
okay
um you love a good addiction story right
so essentially the question is bad
habits versus addiction what is the
difference yes
um
and there is a difference there's a
difference between what a habit is and
what an addiction is
um a habit can be like a persistent you
know behavior that you perpetuate and it
might even have negative consequences
but the difference between that and in
addiction is that addiction entails a
psychological uh and and generally also
sometimes also a physical dependence and
there's a discomfort when we don't
engage in the addiction right that sense
of of withdrawal or like craving or
yearning it's something that we we do
repeatedly despite negative
repercussions
addictions are are things that typically
escalate over time whether it's Behavior
um the frequency of use the dosage of
use in the case of substances
um
and and we do this uh irrespective of
escalating negative consequences right I
think there's also like a compulsivity
to addictions that are that's different
from just a bad habit
um where there's this physiological
again or psychological need for for for
engaging in in this habit
um
and and when we don't do it there is
there are symptoms right anxiety
irritability uh you know there's
physical symptoms with substances like
Tremors or nausea upon withdrawal or
abstinence that is the state of of being
addicted right and I think addiction and
I've said this many times is is
something that is a self-diagnosis like
you only you can diagnose yourself as to
whether you are engaging in addictive
behavior or just a bad habit and I think
uh in in trying to figure that out for
yourself
and distinguishing a habit from an
addiction think about choice right like
with habit Choice plays a larger role
with addiction part of addiction is is
uh the removal or the denigration of
choice in the matter
to the point where it doesn't feel like
there is a choice like there is such a
compulsion that it just happens and
you're being automated you know your
your wish to have a choice over it it
like happens no matter what I mean I
think that's a good kind of litmus test
for figuring it out
um
so examples right like a bad habit would
be
like you you know you just put your
dirty dishes in the sink and you don't
wash them or like you don't brush your
teeth before you go to bed or something
like that right not great you know this
is not awesome habits uh but is there
compulsivity around it is there a sense
of unease when you wash your dishes
you're not you know you're not just
leaving them dirty in the sink no it's
right so that's the difference between
you know something that would be an
addiction
um so you would put gaming more into the
addiction category yeah well I don't
know you know only he he has to ask
himself that right there are people that
play video games and who are not
addicted and there are people who are
addicted and often the the amount of
playing isn't necessarily the
determining Factor
you know I think a lot of that's the
problem with smartphones a lot of people
are addicted to the tech now right it's
low level but like they can't put their
phone down they can't stop scrolling no
right of course not right and it's it's
not is it low level no maybe not you
know and this is this is you know I've
been banging this drum for a while but
let's expand our notion of of addiction
and how we think about addiction like
addiction isn't just alcoholics and drug
addicts or people that you know lose all
their money gambling yeah it is you know
the the the the inability to like
you know put down the phone
can be an addiction but it is you know
taking you out of the present and
robbing you of the experience of of
being in your life right uh video games
are you know another screen version of
that where there's an engagement on
behalf of the individual but certainly
you know plenty of people are addicted
to video games yes and the fact that
this guy like cratered his Iron Man
training because he got all caught up in
a video game I mean that's what it
sounds like I don't know the details of
it but it sounds like an addiction to me
but again like it's not for me to
diagnose this person questions to ask
that that this person or whoever is
relating to this should ask themselves
is
you know do you feel like this is a
compulsion do you feel like your
engagement with it is outside of your
control is it something you covet is it
something that you uh you know tell lies
about that you rationalize or downplay
and then getting honest about what the
costs of of of this Behavior are to
yourself and also to other people right
and then the other question I had is
kind of going behind the question like
the question is is this a bad habit or
an addiction like why is he asking this
question if he's asking the question
it's probably a problem if it's not a
problem you're not asking this question
no and there's sort of a light dusting
of hopeful hopefulness that like I'm
gonna say this is just a bad habit and
don't worry about it like does it matter
what I say is this a bad habit is this
an addiction because my sense is that
this is interfering with this person's
well-being right and he knows it and
he's looking for an excuse or some way
to rationalize continuing to engage in
the behavior which is to me in disha of
it being an addiction
does that make sense yes
absolutely
like like you already know it's not good
for you you know it needs to be
addressed right this is why you're
asking because you're not just asking
your friend you're calling a line
there's like a lot of decisions you have
to make yeah like you to get this person
knows the answer to the question already
right and and maybe that answer is
uncomfortable but
um you know deep down when the head hits
the pillow
the clarity is there yeah
that's why I haven't been Insomniac
the The Hive of the brain stop what are
you hiding what are you running away
from it's so deeply hidden I can't tell
you right well maybe you need to go to
the sky cave Retreat and sit with
yourself in the dark for six days I
think I would try to get the room
something would come up next to Colin
and I would just be like Morse code hey
there must be there must be some of that
like it would be so interesting to know
like whoever the people that own that
place must have stories right about
people losing their minds exactly like
did you get the chocolate pudding or
just the jello because this is [__] food
so like how would you I don't know and
so many questions anyway let's go to the
next all right next one question
how do you speak to friends or family
members about lifestyle changes that
might help them when is it time to help
and when is it better to let them
struggle and come out of it on their own
this is a kind of a composite of a
handful of questions yeah of people and
you know we've asked we've answered kind
of something like this before but I
think it's it always Bears repeating
some of the stuff
yeah it's it's this is a very tricky
delicate thing yeah and you know by
lifestyle changes that could mean like
hey don't eat crappy food eat this food
or you know maybe don't stay up all
night or maybe don't drink so much right
you know or you know it could be
anything right but
you know one of the things that that
I've learned in recovery is that I I you
know I just don't like I I stay out of
giving advice or trying to change other
people and I try to just keep my side of
the street clean and for people that are
interested happy to share my experience
so that's kind of the general way that I
approach all of this stuff so I do have
this default reluctance
um or or kind of uh you know reflex to
hold back from getting involved in
solving other people's problems
especially when it comes to Lifestyle
Changes which you know often can be the
most recalcitrant of problems to change
and there's there's a I recognize
there's a little bit of irony in this
because this show and and what I do is
you know fundamentally about change
right how can we be better serving as
this sort of change agent as you will
but
but if you pay attention to the show I
think you'll find that it's quite rare
that I ever tell anyone what to do or
not to do right right like
you know my my you know I I'm always
trying to kind of abstain from judgment
or taking other people's inventory
or providing any kind of unsolicited
advice and and this is especially true
in my experience when it comes to
friends and family uh and again another
built-in irony here is that you know the
people that you care the most about
um are often you know the people that
are the most difficult to reach and that
and and you know myself or whoever is
trying to carry this message are often
the exact people that they can't hear
the advice from right like you're just
too close to them and I have countless
examples of you know family members
friends
uh you know people who I've worked with
who you know like like I can through the
show and books and all these things that
I do like I carry a certain message
right right and and I try to be divorced
from how that lands or whether it
impacts people or changes them or not
but with family members like you know
there's like a force field around it
like they can't hear it from you like
you're the kid that you know like
because also know they also know where
it's not you're not always you're not
always as uh as perfect as it might
sound right yeah yeah of course so
they've got all that stuff right so
after like you know doing this for so
long and then suddenly you know
somebody's like hey I just you know I'm
I'm 30 days plant-based or I did that
and I was like great like how did that
happen oh I heard I read this book from
like somebody else or some other some
other like on YouTube or something like
that has nothing to do with me and it's
always funny it's like right here I've
been right here the whole time kind of
saying the same thing but like okay
that's great you know like but that's
the way it works right yes
um that is the way it works friends and
family like they you know you can't
like you can't make somebody willing to
change and when you're kind of forcing
your idea like you've had okay let's say
you've made a lifestyle change and it's
improved your life and you're
enthusiastic about that and of course
you want to evangelize that but that
makes you annoying and people don't want
to hear that right like right no you
know that you be you become like uh the
antithesis of what you're trying to
accomplish in that other person
you're more like be the example you're a
lighthouse you put it out there the
lights on and live your life yeah you
know yeah live your life I would say
that
the exception is that
um the exception is when the advice or
is solicited like if somebody comes to
you and says hey I need help like can
you help me here's what I'm work you
know struggling with or do you have any
advice for me that's a different
situation
um and I think in those cases
the response that I generally offer is
like do you want me to tell you what I
think and give you advice or do you want
me to just listen to you and and be
supportive because those are two
different things and sometimes people
who are coming to you under the root
under the kind of auspices of seeking
advice actually they just want to be
heard yes and listen to yes and they
don't really want you to tell them what
to do
um so getting clarity about that I think
is important they don't want your dime
store with no they don't right
um and so behind all of this is
willingness right willingness is what
drives transformation and you know
without willingness and by willingness I
mean you know that that that internal
desire to change that is driven from
within the self and not impulsed by
something external
um any kind of sustainable change is is
impossible right and you can't will
somebody to be willing no you can't
compel somebody to be willing no matter
how much they're suffering or no matter
how much you think you have the solution
for them they have to decide for
themselves that they want that and you
being in the position of trying to
convince them
um not only you know how to change but
that they should change is really kind
of a Fool's errand and it's a mistake
that that I see a lot of people make
often and I think in those cases
you're probably better off like leaving
the person alone letting them know that
you love them and that you're available
for them if and when they want to do
something different than whatever it is
that they're doing but in the meantime
like allow them to to be because
uh perhaps they need to uh you know be
in the world and have this experience
that might actually catalyze that
internal willingness right at some point
you don't want to Rob them of that but
it's hard it's hard to watch people
struggle I mean I think that's where
this is especially when it's somebody
that you care about right imagine your
child of course imagine my parents when
I was doing what I was doing like it's
it's it's this is like the hardest thing
yeah
it's really hard like when do you
intervene when do you you know try to
help when do you say enough is enough
and you step aside like
these are very difficult you know
situations and it's a case-by-case thing
life does not [__] around does it rich
no
um anything else there any other
thoughts that I have on that
um I think I would just say
for that person that you're seeking to
you know be of service to I don't see a
problem in in testing the waters from
time to time for example just you know
kind of
calling them up or you know getting
together with them and then you know
posing
it as a question like hey how's that
thing going for you like you happy like
what's going on like trying to strip any
judgment or a kind of veneer of like you
know
like I'm here to change you or help you
just like get rid of that and just be
curious about it or even just hang out
like you could just say hey I'd like to
take you to lunch or I'd like you I'd
like to like let's go watch a concert or
something and just hang out right and
not even bring it up and yeah and
sometimes that's the thing to do to
reach somebody right but when it's
family that's pretty hard to do because
there's so much history in baggage like
oh you want to take me out to lunch what
are you going to tell me what to do with
that you know it's like it's already
[__] up yeah so you know this is why I
should not it's not it's not am a dam
and uh ask me Adam anything it's not 8
am it's okay AMA anyway those are my
thoughts on that I don't know if that's
don't listen to me but folks cool
um let's do one or two more yeah so this
is a another one in spite a lot of
people called in with they knew someone
that uh they want you to interview or
that or they had a recommendation for
someone they admire they want to
interview Josh Lewis recommended Bob
Weir the great legendary Bob Weir The
Grateful Dead for the Pod
um I've mentioned Henry Rollins to you
in the past we talked about that
privately and I'm just curious if you
want to give us your list of rockers and
musicians at the top of your your pod
guest wish list and um and then also if
you want to talk to the folks who just
tell them because people are asking
about booking people like how do you
generally select guests and book them
right so those are two questions yeah I
mean the the the the general question
around selecting and booking guests is
kind of an evolving
um thing and something I've put a lot of
thought into when I was taking my
sabbatical I have some ideas about how
to do that differently I would say in
general like I keep a working list like
a spreadsheet like anytime I come across
somebody who I think would be cool I add
them to this list I try to figure out
who to contact or who knows who to you
know so it's we don't work with a
booking agency uh you know nobody else
books the show except me nobody else
decides who's in going to be on the show
except me so it's all about like who I'm
curious about and then who I kind of
pursue and some of these people like I
don't I'm like how am I going to figure
out how to get to I don't know who you
know like I can DM them on Instagram but
you know short of that like
um it's difficult so a lot of these take
a long time and there's a lot of no's
and I think I also have you know if I'm
being honest about my weaknesses with
this I've been overly reactive in terms
of booking the show as opposed to
proactively going after the people I
really want you know and I I've never
been super systematic or about the whole
thing and I think I have a lot of room
for improvement there and that's one
thing I want to do better this year than
I've done in the past because the shows
at a scale right now where I get a lot
of incoming you know and I have a lot of
hey you know friends who recommend or
whatever and so it's pretty easy to be
like oh that that would be cool yeah
sure I'll do that like that's being kind
of responsive to easy stuff to fill the
slots people yeah and and it's and one
but I'd like to think of it differently
from the point of view that
over the course of a year with the
exception of the master classes and the
best doves and the roll-ons and things
like that I have about 50 open slots for
the year
who are the 50 best people in the world
that I can get to come here and sit down
with me like looking at it not like oh
that would be cool let's do that and
being very casual about it I'd like to
be a lot more
um
conscious and intentional about really
going after the people that I want the
most and I think what has traditionally
gotten in my way is somebody to say oh
you should get this person in some like
fancy I was like I don't know that but
they don't want to do it you know like I
get I uh I get self-defeating about it
like why would they come talk to me you
know right as opposed to you know just
having more at bats and if they say no
fine but like try
you know but so the answer is like yeah
I have a list and you know I'm in
communication with lots of people at any
given moment and sometimes it takes a
long time before the schedule's aligned
because we only do it in person
um but every time I come across somebody
interesting they get added to that list
and and so I kind of slowly work my way
through that list in terms of musicians
that's the other part of the question
yes who are the musicians that are on
who's on that list who's on that list uh
there's some interesting ones I mean I'm
not going to go through all of them but
maybe the ones that are most interesting
Dave Grohl number one on that list yes
gotta get Dave Grohl on I listened to
his audiobook when I was in Australia
it's it's good man have you read his
book I have not it's I I should it's
super I'm gonna get the audience I mean
like that dude is awesome of course yeah
so he's up there flea is up there
another incredible all right
I love flea I I love we're both Laker
fans he was watching a Lakers on his
iPad in Australia while playing Bridge
Over Troubled Water because it's that
it's been a fraught season
um and I just I sometimes I watch that
Australian too yeah
yeah both had both his parents were
Australian yeah
um who else uh Bruce Dickinson from Iron
Maiden I'm not like a heavy metal guy
but this guy's life story is bananas so
until I'm uh you're saying he flies his
own he flies his own plane he has like
such a diversity of expertise and and
like different things that he's into so
yeah he became a commercial pilot like
when Iron Maiden was huge and uh and
started a whole like aircraft
maintenance and pilot training company
um and he he would fly the band in a 757
like he piloted the band in their own
757. so the reason that's amazing to me
is because in Bali I can't tell you how
many times because I I used to cover
Indonesia a lot for little on the planet
and and every almost a lot of times not
every time I frequently would fly into
Bali and see in and out of Bali and see
Iron maiden's plane like that's him yeah
so he flies it so he has a he's in Bali
a lot obviously apparently yeah I don't
know about that he also writes novels
and film scripts and like yeah I mean
just like Google the guy it's like it's
crazy you gotta get him it's perfect for
you yeah Dave Grohl Bruce Dickinson flee
uh Michael Stipe top of the list too I'm
impressive REM fan uh did you hear
Courtney Love on Marc maron's podcast if
not you gotta check that out oh well
it's wild all right like wild I can't
tell whether she's a genius or like
bananas or somewhere in between but
she's got stories she has stories you
know it's kind of amazing she's gotta
have more stories yeah uh I think Bjork
would be incredible yeah I think Sinead
O'Connor would be amazing I mean her
life and kind of how she was treated and
everything that happened with her yeah
um does Bo Burnham count of course Bo
Burnham is incredible yeah
um I tried to get Tom Morello a while
back I think he had a book coming out
and I went through a publicist he said
no really I might have to revisit that I
mean you know who else Tom York Trent
rezner
um one one one uh musician who I quite
fancy who people might not be familiar
with
is this film composer called Ludwig
Goranson yes Swedish composer uh he
wrote the score for Black Panther the
score for the Mandalorian he works with
Christopher Nolan he wrote the score for
tenants and the score for the upcoming
Oppenheimer movie he also produced
Childish Gambino and like this guy's
cool like he makes these videos where
you're in his studio and he'll show you
his process like he goes through the
whole thing about how he came up with
the theme for the Mandalorian oh really
working with all these weird instruments
and how it all came together and I'll
put links up to some of those videos in
the um
in the show notes and he he's kind of
like the new kid in terms of advancing
what a film score can be
um like iterating on on like you know
kind of a new like new sound modalities
for film like if you go and like really
listen to the music in tenant like it's
it's pretty wild what he does in that
movie so anyway I would love to sit down
with him cool
I'm glad I asked you that question yeah
it was kind of a paraphrase but also
that was my my curiosity that's
interesting to anybody but anyway all
right look the way you choose your guess
is interesting and all of that and the
fact that you've been reactive now
you're going to be more proactive
hopefully event and and and you know try
to break down these publicists who are
these publicists working with the old
game you know old media don't get me
started keep going
foreign
then there were a lot of messages
messages from listeners who were
actually just calling to thank you you
know and uh for a show that enriches
their lives
um and I just thought it was cool
because
it just shows you know then they would
talk about how they recommend it to
friends where they would they would
recommend their friends and mentors to
you to be their get to be to be guests
on the show it just speaks of this
powerful connection Word of Mouth
phenomenon and how the branches kind of
Link back and forth and uh you know so I
just thought I wanted to share that with
you having having gone through so many
of these messages and curious about how
that makes you feel hearing that yeah
it's it's it's weird you know on some
level I mean it's incredibly gratifying
uh the fact that this thing that you
know we started 10 years ago on a
creative whim without any kind of plan
and and just sort of nurtured with love
and Curiosity has like grown into this
thing that I would have never imagined
and it didn't it didn't happen because
of any kind of like business plan or
anything like that and we've never
advertised or bought reach or done any
kind of paid promotion
um you know we've never really had a a
viral moment that produced any kind of
huge gross bike I mean we've had some
shows that have done well the human one
in particular which did like 12 million
I guess so that would be an outlier but
in general like it's just been this very
slow creep of you know growing the show
gradually and organically
um it's it's it's the analogy is like
being an ultra endurance athlete right
like slow and steady wins the race like
running the tortoise
um the prize doesn't go the fastest it
goes to the guy who slows down the least
and and we've just maintained a certain
Pace over a very long period of time
when we began we were kind of in the
right place at the right time there's a
lot of luck involved and then a lot of
work that went into the into it behind
the scenes that that you know made it
what it is today
um which like I said is very gratifying
it's it's you know it's an incredible
thing that
I feel incredibly privileged like I just
you know I get to do this thing every
day like are you kidding it's amazing
um but it can be a little bit weird and
surreal at times because there's this
parasocial relationship with the
listener yes uh that occurs that that
can create some kind of strange
Encounters in the world but also nice
and they're things that you know I don't
I don't deal with really when I'm at
home but when I travel and I'm at
airports or in different cities
and I get approached quite a bit but
it's always like
like there's all when somebody comes up
to me it's almost as if we have a
pre-existing relationship like they
already know me like I'm their friend
that they just they were just with the
other day and like oh now he's here now
so I'm gonna go say hi to him right
right right like but it's a one-sided
thing right you know and and so there is
a little bit of awkwardness with that
but it's actually it's really
it's um it's very endearing like and and
and I guess you know the main thing in
terms of like what I could impart to The
Listener or the the viewer is that this
experience has proven to me that we're
all more powerful than we think we are
especially in this internet era where
anybody can you know go online with a
camera or a microphone and and and share
you know share themselves
um and the fact that you know I'm just a
guy and I started this thing and over
time it's become important to other
people and like I don't have any more
ownership over it than than the audience
does like it's as much theirs as it is
you know mine or the team of talented
people that I now surround myself with
that work really hard to create this
thing every week like they they work
harder you know or at least as hard as I
do right to do this so it's really not
about me I think it's really about the
power of the individual to to produce
change like if I could do this thing
like I just think everybody has
something inside of them
um that they could express to make the
world a little bit of a better place uh
and you know if I could do this thing
and and perhaps change people's lives a
little bit
um
I think everybody you know can make a
difference in the world and and I can
tell you that being engaged in the
process of like trying to offer
something positive to the world and and
and not get caught up in metrics and
well that guy's doing this and he's
bigger than me and like why is that
guest doing that you know like when I
get for when I free myself of all of
that noise and just remember like why it
is that we're doing this
um it's just it's just like an
overwhelming sense of like gratitude so
I want everyone to feel
you know their version of of that and I
think it's we're in a time in a in a
place where that's more possible than it
ever has been in history well said well
said we have one more department but we
do that the media diet we got to do with
the media diet we're doing the media
diet
one more Department the media diet all
right introduce this so I was uh Joanne
Molinaro the Korean vegan had us over
for dinner the other night and she was
saying how she loved knowing that you're
a binge watching geek just like everyone
else yeah
it's so funny because I I see her at the
gym and she's like oh I I like figured
out what to like stream because I was
like really yeah like you might be the
only one but okay so you had a lot of
time on your hands yeah in the sky Cave
of Byron
um did you do some binge watching did
you stream or not I tried not to stream
too much but I did I did uh I you know I
did I did watch a few things so tell us
the highlights yeah I don't want to make
like a huge thing of this I did one
thing that I do every year which is I
watched I rewatched Michael Clayton
because I need to watch that movie every
single I love myself one of the greatest
movies I've ever made fantastic I love
Michael I love it so much it's like an
old school suspense movie you know like
one back like yeah but some great
performances it's fantastic right it is
it is the I don't know it's everything
that I love in a movie I love it now and
I think Tony Gilroy who wrote directed
that movie uh is now applying his
talents uh beautifully in Andor which is
the Star Wars spin-off uh oh that's
memories yeah Tony Gilroy created that
so
uh that would be another streaming
recommendation that's also great for the
family and the kids and all of that uh
you know I'm somebody who likes Star
Wars but I'm not like a huge Star Wars
person and now in this extended Star
Wars Universe of like all these shows
and all these movies it's sort of like
really
um but Andor stands apart
um on a quality level it's like I've
heard and Tony loves doing it like he
he's like in his prime he gets to write
the stuff that he cares about and the
themes that he explores in his movies
are explored in andoral It's like Star
Wars for grown-ups okay and it's almost
not even Star Wars like with the
occasional
TIE fighter flies by but like you could
forget it's even Star Wars it's just a
very well crafted story about about
economic disparity Uprising Revolution
uh you know it's it's political in that
regard like early like the first part of
Hunger Games it's it's like the early
part of the Rebellion like what caused
the Rebellion what is actually happening
what is the Empire doing to these people
that's causing them to want to rebel so
it's classic Sci-fi Parable to the uh to
the present day it's good
um what else uh I I watched uh you know
a lot of a lot of the movies that I
watch are re-watches okay I rewatch
Broadcast News I re-watch Copland which
is Sylvester Sylvester Stallone's best
movie never seen it you've never seen
koplin never seen it come on man uh also
hot take hot take have you seen the
informants
my hot take is that this might be Matt
Damon's best performance of any movie I
like them in siriana
yeah I think that to me that's and I
also I mean he's amazing and Talented Mr
Ripley I I really like syriana syriana
got like a bad rap from the critics I
don't know why I think it's great I do
too and I love Stephen gagan I think
he's an amazingly talented amazing uh
filmmaker yeah yeah who who wrote a
great writer too yeah
um and amazing Storyteller who would be
welcome on this podcast at any time yes
I love it I don't know why people didn't
like I like syriana very much yeah
um I re I rewatched A A little known uh
series called Rubicon on AMC which is
kind of like hard-boiled you know spy
trade craft I love that stuff anyway
what are we talking about here like I
you know I watched White Lotus I like
that I want to shout out the climb okay
the Jason Momoa and Chris Sharma
series uh which is really people love
that I have not seen it yet really good
yeah
um last of us are you in the last of us
I am because my kids are super into it
yeah and I've enjoyed that you know yeah
of course you are we talked about
cordyceps we just got into it
uh and uh I guess one other one other
kind of off-kilter series that I would
recommend on Netflix is song Exploder
it's based on the podcast songs
yeah when the REM they have a season two
up right now there's only like four
episodes per season or whatever but I
just really love that show it's
fantastic and then in terms of podcasts
because we're talking about streaming
podcast Falls in that I enjoyed this
limited series called the new gurus by
Helen Lewis he's a writer for the
Atlantic each episode uh kind of uh
looks at this secular Guru landscape
kind of in the way that the decoding the
gurus guys do it
um but she does it in a documentary kind
of style and it kind of Paints the
picture of what this new world of
Internet gurus looks like and what it's
doing to people and where it's working
and where it's going sideways and you
know Helen is very
introspective and insightful uh on this
subject matter that's cool check that
out yeah I had to shake her she was
trying to tell me here earlier a Shaker
I had to shake her she was trying to
help me here yeah
she's gonna knock on our door she
actually just wrote a really amazing
piece for uh for for the Atlantic I'm
pulling it up right now it's called the
internet loves an extremophile oh
um
the subtitle is online culture favors
influencers Who Pinball from one
enthusiasm enthusiasm to the next uh
it's a it's a pretty great long raid
yeah I'll link that up in the show notes
as well let's do that um but yeah I
don't know cool what have you been
enjoying
um I uh so far I haven't seen too many
movies we saw we saw everything
everywhere all at once really like that
obviously
um saw White Lotus uh love White Lotus
uh The Last of Us
um we're just getting into now uh but I
think of all the things that I've seen
or heard
um
I've been you know what stuck with me
the most is David sedaris's uh new
uh audiobook happy-go-lucky it's like I
think it's probably the most
uh prescient uh percent prescient
uh take on
the pandemic and and the lifestyle that
we all kind of had to uh uh Undertake
and his responses to it I mean if you
don't obviously David Sayers he's he's a
master at the height of his powers here
he's meant to be heard not just read
he's so great when he reads it himself
it's um he unpacks his life story and
puts his his family members he he
basically puts the light on everything
and he he really I mean he's merciless
but uh in the end there's so many
poignant moments and you you learn about
kind of his relationship with his father
you learn about his relationship with
his siblings
um you learn his own quirks
um and he's just obviously hilarious I
mean I think he he to me he's a
descendant of Mark Twain I know Mark
Twain is a master novelist he's not a
novelist so it's it's not exactly a
great comparison but in terms of an
American humorist who kind of can can
nail the the American culture so so
easily and mercilessly here's a guy that
does
um it's it is laugh out loud funny and
cringy and awesome happy go lucky
happy-go-lucky I will definitely check
that out of audible I love that guy yeah
and I I I've been listening to dialogue
by Robert McKee I know he's a guest
that's coming up yeah he's coming up I
know soon you know like
working on this other project for so
long like I get so crazy is it good is
it gonna suck whatever and so like I
ended up diving into like writing
like how to become a writer I'm like I'm
like learning to be a writer and so I
found this book and the one thing I will
say I don't want to I don't know if he
talks about Shakespeare do you guys talk
about Shakespeare in your podcast we
recorded it so long ago did we talk
about that I don't think so so one thing
I'll say because I'm the one of those
writers I'm not the guy who's in love
with Shakespeare like I never I like
certain plays but I'm not I'm I'm not
you know to me Shakespeare is awesome I
like certain plays but I've never been
the the guy that has to read everything
um and sometimes I think you know why is
it overblown but what I didn't realize
and what he says in dialogue is that
Shakespeare invented like thousands of
words that have become part of the
English language lexicon among them
elbow eyeball like when he needed a word
he made up the word
um that comes out of dialogue by Robert
McKee and so like that that's why
there's basically ding ding ding that's
why there's this Obsession among so many
people in English departments with
Shakespeare because he he CR he didn't
just entertain he crafted the the
Lexicon we're all using now does that
mean that we're allowed to make up words
now yes okay yes yes yes yes
that's cool yeah I didn't know that wow
interesting
um
I forgot to mention that you know on the
on the tip of like sharing movie stuff
yeah
you know I did spend New Year's Eve at
the arrow theater in Santa Monica
enjoying a 70 millimeter print of 2001 A
Space Odyssey so because that that
should like ensure my like film nerd
card oh yeah I would spend New Year's
Eve big time
that sounds like a great New Year's Eve
actually it was awesome
was it just you and Julie and Jaya oh
cool that's pretty cool that's a great
one
um my favorite I should we'll wrap it up
like my favorite movies of this year the
Oscar nominations just came out yep
I still think
I mean tar is incredible I gotta see it
you haven't seen Target I gotta see all
these that yeah I'm glad I got
everything everywhere all at once you
know it it felt like maybe that came out
too soon but then it got like I want to
get like 11 nominations do you think
it's gonna win
I feel like it's gonna win I think it I
think it's in a good position yeah
um banshees of inner Sharon incredible
I love that movie you haven't seen it
not yet I even though I I you know In
Bruges
brilliant in that movie yeah the movie
that I think got
sort of dismissed or overlooked uh maybe
this is a hot take but I really like
this movie as white noise yeah some
people didn't like it right yeah yeah
um
book no a bomb back like it takes a lot
of big swings and it maybe it doesn't
always connect but
um
I don't know man I dug it
it's built for middle-aged guys trying
to figure out what life's all about yeah
my choices are are like well not you
know like I like spy stuff like I'm dead
core like give me Jack Ryan on Amazon
like I'm happy you know what I mean yes
you are dead Corey so uh and then the
other the other movie that I really
enjoyed
um is triangle of sadness I don't know
if you saw it I've heard that's amazing
fantastic we got to watch all these
we're just reading more in the meantime
go see Megan because that movie [__]
rules Megan yeah the AI robot that goes
on a killing spree come on Adam that
sounds like Terminator Terminator it's
the little girl four foot tall girl oh
he was not a killing Rampage
come on
all right I think I'm high bro is AI is
AI a good idea well go see Megan and
decide I've already seen Terminator why
are we doing AI it's a bad idea
please go see Megan okay and uh we will
reprise roll on again soon right but not
in this is this is this it for this yeah
there'll be a little kibbid thing we
gotta have some pivots and uh you know
like I said you guys let us know leave a
comment on YouTube all right tell us
what you think okay is that it we're out
that's good all right thanks everybody
Welcome to 2023. Adam so good to see you
I love you buddy I love you too man
thanks for having me cool [__] this year
let's do it all right cheers peace
ice ice
[Music]